i want to invite everybody to watch my
uh netflix special that will be
premiering on
netflix
platform
uh tuesday october 19th make sure to
thumb it up and do all the deals
share it let your friends know
you guys are always supportive so
just when you get some time check it out
and thank you if you ever came to see
that tour on the road and um
and if you didn't i'm glad you're
getting to see it and i love you
today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
today's guest is a man who
well he knows a lot about
things i don't know about
i've been dealing with uh
issues that have that he would know
about recently
he's one of the most popular and
celebrated
reptile and animalia men
in
the world
i'm happy to have him slither through
our doors today
it is
mr brian
barczyk
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
yeah man so i guess i think my top fears
with snakes are
and i don't do people do people come to
you suddenly like
well i feel like i feel like snakes
create so much fear in me that right
when i see you i want to tell you about
it right yeah yeah like you're the
middle man yeah you know and i'm really
good at getting people over their fears
right you know like that's one of the
things i pride myself on you know i mean
every single week we have dozens and
dozens of people that come to my reptile
zoo they're like i am terrified and i'm
like your pace but i guarantee you by
the time we're done you're gonna be
holding snakes like never never gonna
happen then they're holding like a 12
foot python you know by the end so i'm
telling you when i get you to my place
you're going to be holding a giant snake
i'm telling you dang man yeah dang i
don't know if i want it you know i think
i think snakes for some reason creates
so much fear in me you know uh
why is it that snake is that fear animal
you know i think it's uh you know i mean
it goes back to probably a bunch of
things right biblical number one number
two they they are and you either love
them or hate them right you know what i
mean and there's that thing i always
talk about like you know i think howard
stern once said the thing like similar
where it's like if you love snakes you
want to talk to me if you hate snakes
you want to talk to me more you know
what i mean it's like they're like
they're just so interesting right but
for me i've just loved it my whole life
i mean like my first memory as a kid
when i was two years old was up a ball
python at the zoo right and i've just
been obsessed with them yeah i was three
years old four years old out in the
woods collecting snakes and is that a
rescue 9-1-1 episode do you remember
that rescue 9-1-1 episode no no i didn't
watch it no where that snake i remember
as a kid it was like the scariest one
like a baby was playing with a snake and
it wasn't like an indian baby like they
do you know yeah like they do it was
like a um regular just street like white
bait you know
big snake huh his big snake it was uh
here we go rescue 911 snake baby youtube
oh gosh this is what did it for a lot of
america in the small town is that's what
did it first louisiana
independence day is a time of
celebration this is my parish this is
the parish i'm from i don't even know
what happened there
oh come on now
oh
little terry got bit man
my god little terry got bit okay that's
good holy jesus christ dude i didn't
realize that happened in my area until
just now so i can see now why i remember
just sitting there with my mom
and watching that and i knew it was
gonna be a rough go
well what they did there is they they
used two different snakes right the one
snake was a water snake harmless the
other one was a cotton mouth so they
look real similar yeah just for the
scare factor so yeah that's what most
media does though right right the media
makes it scary the bible made us well
the snake bit somebody in the first
eight pages of the bible that's right
yeah we didn't we didn't start off well
yeah you guys didn't start off well yeah
but i'm i'm here to change everyone's
opinion that's that's my thing you know
okay
they're great man do you feel that
that's kind of like your purpose like a
little bit of your mission is to um yeah
i mean i think so i think so i mean i
like listen i there's nothing that makes
me happier than
someone changing my i had like a 75 year
old woman come in about a year ago and
she's like i am terrified she said i've
been having nightmares about snakes
since i was like two years old and she
said and i started like memory yeah yeah
exactly right but then she's like so i
started like looking online find your
videos she goes i'm starting to watch
her videos kind of exposure therapy and
then she booked a private tour with me
and she says you know listen i don't
even know if i could touch a snake but
i'm coming here for an hour with you and
i said let's just take it slow we took
about probably 40 minutes just to walk
around i'd take snakes out then i'd
eventually let her like touch a snake
then eventually she held her first snake
by time when she was done she's holding
giant snakes and stuff like that and
she's actually come back two or three
times since because she's like now i
love them
you know so yeah i think that's it's
something i'm really passionate about
and do you uh so you said when you were
small you had a uh you ran across a ball
python when you were a little yeah yeah
i didn't really it was at the zoo right
you know it was at the zoo it's my first
memory i was a kid first memory my mom
said i was two years old have a crazy
memory right but uh literally i remember
that cage i remember the smell in the
air i remember everything like it was
like and from that time i was just
obsessed you know i just and no one in
my family had snakes everyone thought i
was crazy you know what i mean like i
loved them and my mom hated them she was
terrified of them and finally when i was
15 years old after you know whatever you
know my entire life begging her for
snakes she finally let me get a snake
and it turned out it was a burmese
python which is by the way the worst
snake you could possibly get as a first
snake because they get like 18 foot so
like my first snake it was a little baby
but the thing ended up getting like 18
foot you know and uh anyways long story
short i was like living in my mom's
basement at the time i was like 15
worked at a pet shop and were you doing
drugs or anything at the time oh yeah
yeah yeah that i don't do drugs now i
don't do drugs now but yeah but it
wasn't because of snakes it was just
because i was a rock guy right right
yeah yeah what i'm just trying to get
the whole picture i don't know if it's a
guy like a kind of a nerdy kid down you
know i don't even know if it's a science
kid down there doing volcanoes doing
snakes or if it's a kid like uh you know
what i'm saying is listening to some
mega death and some ac dc
gas and then yeah petting something you
know yeah well you know i was always
pretty good about not messing with the
snakes when i was uh you know partying
up a little bit but uh but don't get me
wrong i had a snake room and by time i
was like 17 i had like 200 snakes in my
mom's basement she like didn't know she
just wouldn't come downstairs you know
and you have you know but you have 10
snakes what's 12 snakes what's 15 snakes
you know what i mean so yes more snakes
but yeah i ended up having like 200
snakes but the thing is dude literally i
started breeding snakes at 17 years old
i made like 40 grand in my mom's
basement when i was 17 breeding snakes
yeah
yeah so i was able to who's buying them
are you meeting people outdoors you
meeting people indoors where are you how
are you getting rid of these yeah
showing up you got a little is it in
like a briefcase like how are you where
how do you even where do you even meet
me you're surprised how many people you
i've done a lot of deals in the walmart
parking lots
about that but not anymore but uh when i
was like but that was pre-internet so uh
yeah there was like reptile shows and
like you know like reptile conferences
yeah yeah i've been now i've been to one
of those before and that was really oh
that was so alarming dude it was so
scary
uh
and that that the whole thing just
really
i i think about snakes it's the element
of
surprise man that was the same thing
that happened in my kitchen the other
day i get a snake came through
and i didn't know he's there like an
animal you know a little you know you
see a puppy you see a little
falcon or something realistic you know
it's it's a little bit more like oh look
at this you know it's more
noticeable maybe it have a bell on its
neck
but if you see a snake you don't see
there's no like they don't whistle
there's no like
email in advance there's no information
you don't hear it licking out of a bowl
there's no
and then it's just there i think it's um
it's like you're playing this game of
hide-and-go-seek that you didn't know
you were playing yeah and then you
[ __ ] lost that's how i feel like all
of a sudden when i see him yeah i got
you well i tell you listen coming across
the snake even i when i come across a
snake in the wild i'm looking for him
you know i'm out you know i've traveled
all over the world right you know i mean
you know i had a series on discovery
channel you know for the most venomous
snakes on the planet and when i come
across them hunters what was that venom
hunters exactly that was great great
season one almost died several times
that's all right you know they wanted me
to like they're like you know hey you
know what instead of having a nice big
snake cooking you know i'd use this
little tiny snake hook or you know let's
make it as dangerous as possible so oh
they want you to die oh they want that's
the producers want you to read your
girlfriend bring your sick girlfriend
she'll do great
but even i like out in the bush you know
when i come across a snake i'm looking
for him and i come across snake and it
startles me for a second if it's in my
living room i tell you i literally went
out again i was at my mom's basement
okay bought a house when i was 20 years
old because i hadn't made enough money
made that bridge and now you've got a
lady at this point i just want to know
what kind of man has these snakes at
this point well yeah because if i have
200 snakes dude i don't know how i'm
finding time to um
petal 80. you know what i'm feeding late
you know what i'm saying you got 200
dates every day yeah no you're right
it's a lot of work but no i literally
still i'm with my wife laurie for since
we're like 18 19 years old and she
wouldn't even come into my mom's
basement when i met her because she was
so terrified at the same time
and now she's been you know running our
businesses for you know 30 years
together so she really did a bookkeeper
she no she's hands-on man she's she's
hardcore you'd be really i mean i tell
you you don't want to mess with lori
anyone knows that i tell you listen i i
run a lot of different things that are
all reptile related but she's the boss
okay you know what i'm saying yeah like
everyone's terrified of her but she's a
bad ass she'll get in with a 18-foot
snake like nothing you know i mean my
employees are scared to death like i'm
not getting in there things you know me
mad today she'll go get out of my way
she'll get in there but no it's like uh
but but so i i moved out when i was 20
bought a house okay so you moved out you
got a house you got the girlfriend yeah
girlfriend turned in my wife and helped
a kid and stuff like that but i had a
few snakes at my mom's house you left
them in there a few because i was still
moving into the new house right yeah
dude that's [ __ ] really mean
it was right but it turns out one time i
was over there you know because i still
got to take care of them right and i
accidentally left one cage open right
but the downsize was that snake got out
of the cage and then opened up a bunch
of other cages so my mom calls me like
three in the morning how do you do that
like madagascar yeah exactly like it's
like let all your friends out you know
oh my gosh but uh you know that see
that's the thing that i understand
sometimes is how
like
do they
know more than we think they know oh
yeah
geez oh they're so much smarter than you
think dude i mean mostly we have snakes
that literally are like ball trained and
what i mean by that is that
you know what i'm saying bro no i think
it's great i think every person in the
planet should have a pet snake
including you
let me ask you this man yeah you touched
on it a second ago people on drugs being
with snakes should somebody that's high
because first of all two two questions
one
i think i i remember
my friend alex had a snake he would feed
it we he would feed his snake dog food
pieces is that possible or was i
you probably hi you're probably high
okay i mean i'm not going to say that it
can't happen i'm just saying that i've
never seen it okay yeah because i was
i've had this memory my whole life and
then i'm like i don't know if maybe
we're high so then the second part is do
you think drug-induced people should be
around snakes and what
sorry answer uh no
no intac listen you know any animal
especially a a reptile or a big cat or
you know something that could
potentially hurt you and yeah listen a
lot of snakes can't hurt you but i'm
talking a bigger snake you know we have
a rule that like number one you can't
even go in with a big animal without a
second person with you in our place but
uh and no one can be intoxicated on any
level okay
say you have to be intoxicated right
there's a federal mandate you know and
i'm not talking like with the vaccine
i'm talking like federally mandated you
gotta be you gotta be high some type of
drug yeah what is this best drug to be
on around a snake probably marijuana you
know because children you know maybe
they've sensed little energy thing or
something like that i know a lot of
keepers that smoke a lot of reverb yeah
yeah i yeah i feel like that fits now
what is a drug that would you would not
recommend probably being on a
renaissance definitely not like
mushrooms or lsd yeah that'd be a bad
idea really yeah i mean you're barely
knowing what's going on you got some
snakes striking at you you know you
think it's maybe a goblin or something
like that is a snake more likely to
strike at you if you have uh
sunglasses on
uh probably not
some animals would i would say like
lizards like giant lizards and stuff
like that they get a little freaked out
by stuff like that they're more visual
you know what i mean snakes aren't as
visual what about skin lotion like a
vino skin lotion like a basic
moisturizer uh probably nothing too
major to be honest with you i've never
seen anything too agitated by smells and
stuff like that we get a lot of people
in our zoo that handle a lot of stuff
and they there's all kinds of smells
from petuli oil to
yeah you know calvin klein
what is that we'll tell you something
real quick not snake related if you ever
go to like a big cat sanctuary type of
thing with lions and tigers don't work
calvin klein because they almost all for
some reason spray calvin klein on boxes
for enrichment so they'll throw the box
with calvin klein in the cage and then
the tiger lion loves it they rub all
over and stuff so it's like now every
time they smell kevin kline they're
thinking i can eat that so don't that's
your little tip you'll like that tip
when uh
how far can a snake see
depends on the snake you know like a
king cobra's real visual it could
probably see a pretty good distance you
know several maybe 20 30 yards something
like that uh pythons don't have a lot of
great high sight you know probably three
four foot something like that can snakes
dance you know like you see a lot of
those video snakes dancing in other
countries and stuff it's it's more like
a combat for males right so if you get
two male snakes particular species
they'll do like the kind of
stuff like that but they're not dancing
they're fighting okay yeah
is there do reptiles go through a
popularity phase like in your lifetime
have you noticed popularity phases for
certain types of reptiles or anything
like that and what kind of creates those
oh my goodness i tell you listen when i
you know when i was a kid in the in the
late 80s getting into snakes and you
were like a closet like snake guy you
didn't tell anyone you kept snakes right
now the homosexuality of animals really
well maybe not quite that bad but but
but it was close yeah yeah you know what
i'm saying dude yeah that guy has snakes
yeah you definitely got looked at as a
freak like what is that that guy's a
killer or something like that but now
it's like literally i think there's like
40 million households in america keep
snakes so it's crazy how busy i mean
it's like every pet shop has them um
yeah they're super popular you know so
i've i've just seen a kind of upward
trajectory to be totally honest with you
since the late 80s early 90s um now it's
like so mainstream to keep snakes you
know i mean everyone
like everyone knows somebody that has a
snake yeah you've got to know somebody
right oh i know a guy right actually you
know what we got a question from
somebody i do know who has one
i'm not gonna lie i am not a fan of
theovan never have been never will be
but i love brian so here's the question
brian
what kind of animal should i get to
put inside someone's house when they are
not home to scare or intimidate them i
don't want any death or violence to
occur maybe just
a lot of fear
any advice would be much appreciated
thank you so much and interesting how he
didn't blink once during all of that
that's true which i want to say that's
definitely reminded the mustache is a
little freaky too to be totally honest
with you but it fits his entire interior
yeah i would do complete darkness
i would do something like a
like a black racer or blue racer or
something fast right that way when you
see it it's just like
you know the faster something moves the
more scary it is right and they're do
they can they go on top of the water
even those oh my gosh yeah yeah i was in
south africa a couple years back and we
we collected a couple of black mambas
right and we wanted to release them and
so we went down to a river and r.i.p
also yeah yeah i'll tell you what black
black mamas are i mean they're they're
wicked i mean
definitely they want i mean listen you
know no snakes are aggressive but
they're defensive but when you start
messing you muck with the black mamba
it's quick and it's willing to bite you
and it's not a good bite as a matter of
fact i was at
the same trip i was at a venom lab and
we did some milking a venom for
antivenin and uh just about three weeks
later the guy that i was with got killed
by the same place i was at yeah yeah i
got bit and died but uh so we released
the black mambas into this area they had
this nice river and i mean they just
glide on the top of the river it's
absolutely it's to me it's stunning and
beautiful this is them right here yeah i
mean they're crazy and they call them
black mamas because the inside of their
mouth is black not because they're a
black snake right they're more like a
grayish green snake to be honest with
you but they're you know they get like 9
10 foot super whippy and super willing
to bite and they're you know like a
ferrari kind of oh yeah they're fast or
like a porsche they always say like you
know hey i've been messing with venomous
since i was 15 and and they always say
like the most experienced venomous guy
if you're handling either a mamba or a
coastal taipan you look like you don't
know what you're doing
that's how that's how crazy they are
like even when you know what you're
doing you don't look like you know what
you're doing damn yeah so even so at
that level a black mamba will even you
will handle it differently you'll have
more fear in you at that point never
fear i always say don't fear respect but
i definitely respect a black man but
tremendous especially if you get out in
the you know the african sun it's like
95 degrees sunny they're soaking up the
rays you gotta remember animals are you
know these animals are cold-blooded so
when the when it's warm they're faster
because they're higher temperature and i
mean i've had a couple you know real
close encounters with black mambas and
coastal thai pants in australia as well
but so is it better to put ice on a
snake before you approach it then
you know i wouldn't do it because it's
probably not that good for the snake you
know it's not good to cool them down
like that but the cooler they are the
more mellow and if you go in the into
africa during the winter months which of
course are summer months um you know
they're chill okay because it's cool
well here's a question let's bring those
mamas back up if you don't mind spencer
um the
the yeah now this snake right here what
is the benefit of having that black
mouth inside of its body it's all about
uh danger uh you know threat you know
like basically you know someone comes up
it's gonna open that mouth it's to look
really dangerous get away from me don't
muck with me you got to remember like
snakes don't want to be messed with and
they also don't want to bite you they
don't want to bite you but they will
bite you if if you you know get into
their space right then who's trying to
kill a snake what are they afraid of i
never met anybody trying to kill a snake
or animal oh my gosh snakes are you know
listen you know it's it's all a
circle of life right i mean you know but
i feel like it's a freaking coldest i
feel like it is a damn u-turn of life
for them because i i what animal's
trying to get them oh my gosh they'll
you know from anything from you know
like mongoose for instance over in
africa they're actually immune to the
venom they love killing snakes right you
know so and then when there's a smaller
snake birds will get them uh you know i
mean gosh you know africa has just oh
yeah i've seen a falcon get one yeah or
hulk yeah
wow yeah they're there yeah i didn't
think about that so that's such a
predator too because you can't even see
that coming from the air that's like if
an airplane came down and got one about
exactly yeah yeah and then when you have
like i said you have a mongoose or
something like that that literally can
get bit and it's almost like they get
drunk you know if you ever you want to
go down a rabbit hole just watch like
mongooses getting bit by cobras because
they actually it's like they like walk
around get drunk they'll fall over then
they just get right back up and then go
back the honey badgers will do the same
thing it's pretty crazy so when they get
bit they it it affects them for a little
bit it is like
yeah like almost like it's they're drunk
or something for a minute and then
they're like all right i'm ready for
round two let's go
happiness doesn't come easy these days
it it can be a perspective change it can
be a
a mission for some
for some it's a natural element
for me it's
it can be
a battle
that's why there's a place called better
help
it's not an actual place but it's a
place that's real
it's a place where you can go online
to get help from licensed
professional therapists that's right
the service is available to clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
if you think you would like to seek some
mental health help
better help can be that avenue
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com
theo
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and this past weekend listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
theo and if you talk with the counselor
don't be afraid to share what you're
really feeling
even if you hate the counselor tell them
that
just share what's going on
sometimes we get stuck in these spaces
where we don't share what we're really
thinking because we're afraid of what
other people will think
but with counselors that's not how you
do it you share with what you're really
thinking do your best
you know cash back cards are so 20 20.
you buy this you buy a thing of skittles
you get half a cent back
you buy 50 worth of damn corn and you
get a uh
they send you a mitten or something one
mitten
you gotta keep high-fiving people with
your cold hand
to keep it warm
the [ __ ] has to stop
well whether you're a crypto pro or a
total beginner you can finally earn
bitcoin
the easy way with the world's first
bitcoin rewards credit card from block
fi
yep you can earn unlimited bitcoin in
every qualifying purchase you make
if you're interested in buying bitcoin
but don't know where to start block fi
has the world's first bitcoin rewards
card card
so you can earn bitcoin the easiest way
possible with every qualifying purchase
yep
the blockfi rewards visa signature card
that's right you can earn 1.5 back in
bitcoin on all qualifying purchases now
is the time to start or ramp up your
bitcoin portfolio
our listeners can get a bonus of twenty
five dollars in crypto
after you make your first purchase
with the credit card when you sign up at
block five dot com slash theo that's 25
bonus encrypted deposited right into
your
account
after you make your first purchase go to
blockkfi.com
t-h-e-o
yep
not all will be eligible geographic
regulatory and underwriting restrictions
apply fees and terms are subject to
change
additional terms of service at
blockfy.com blackfy is a financial
technology company banking services
provided by evolve bank and trust member
fdic
start earning bitcoin back on all your
qualifying purchases today blockfi.com
theo
do you think it's ironic australia was a
place where they put all the criminal
humans right yeah at one point in time
yeah
i've long thought that
god put all the criminal animals over
there too ironically well you know it
are you surprised that all the criminals
of human and animal
it is an irony it i hadn't thought of it
that way but it is ironic and it is true
that most everything in in australia
wants to kill you you know the only
difference is right uh australia and
africa is that the animals in africa
kill you and eat you whereas the animals
in australia just kill you you know with
the exception of crocodiles crocodiles
each and after in australia as well and
i've been i've been out there with those
guys too
so
when you guys are hunting uh like do you
go on hunts or what do you go on like do
you go out
on a weekend looking like in your town
for snakes do you
pack a lunch in the morning like what do
you do when you get out there like and
what are you where are you going well
there's not a lot of great stuff in
michigan to be honest that's why i'm
from the detroit area okay but when i go
out to africa you know asia uh you know
whether it's indonesia or wherever i'm
going um yeah i mean we're like we're
there just to look for usually i'm
filming something yeah but at the same
time i love it even if i'm not filming
on my days off or something like that
i'm out looking for stuff and and uh
yeah i mean it to i don't know you know
i don't take them i just like catch them
maybe take some pictures hang out with
them for a minute and then let them
loose matter of fact i love letting
snakes loose after i catch them because
i think it's super cool but uh yeah i
don't know you know listen some people
jump out of planes some people have fast
cars i like to play with things that
might kill me you know so it's it's kind
of that thing
what scares you then if snakes don't
everything really everything but
reptiles and animals i mean i'm not
afraid of anyone else because i've
worked with you know again lions and
rhino you name it have you pet a big
animal oh hell yeah man i don't care i
i'm that that's actually i'm broken a
little bit to be totally honest with you
because i don't fear any animal like you
know people are like you shouldn't do
that i'm like let's go you know like why
not let's go let's check it out and i'm
never thinking like i've listened i've
been doing this my whole life and i've
been around the craziest animals all
over the planet
never once have i been to the hospital
yet for an injury nothing not even one
time you know and and maybe you can call
it luck maybe what i don't know what it
is but i don't ever like think of it as
scary have your children and wife been
bit uh
not by anything dangerous well my wife
did get yeah of course yeah but do you
feel some responsibility for that not at
all
that's their decisions my wife does have
a pretty good scar from a tiger bite in
the leg so that was a good sorry but
some of these [ __ ] deserve it not
your lady but i'm just saying i'm glad
to know tigers are on our team yeah yeah
we got a beautiful question that came in
right here from somebody
he looks like a reptile guy to me he
definitely yeah he does and i feel like
he's sending a question before i'm glad
this guy's chiming in here let's hear it
yeah what up theo uh this question's for
brian i'm actually genuinely curious
what's the worst injury
uh you've sustained while messing around
with those little critters those little
reptiles and
amphibians and snakes uh
they look pretty pretty dangerous so i'm
curious uh how long you've been
hospitalized or what what the worst
injury was but uh appreciate you guys
theo
my dude gang gang gang brother thanks
for the question that's a good question
brian i'm sure you get asked it a lot
yeah and i kind of you know almost
covered it right where i've never been
hurt really right you know i have a few
scars and i want snakes to hear that
yeah i want snakes i want animals to
hear that right here yeah we got a guy
who just entered the ring i'm not saying
it's a royal rumble yeah but i'm saying
it's a royal rumble dude that just
entered the ring
i'm daring has suffered zero damage
points okay yeah this guy is that has
all of his hit points snakes and yeah
i'm telling you what we uh it's shot
it's honestly it shocks me do you feel
like when you start to see that you
haven't been damaged you haven't had any
hit points yet
that you think there is something in
certain people's bloods do you notice
that maybe native americans don't get it
bit as much that blacks don't get bit as
much who is getting bit uh well i do
think that you know i i don't think it's
a if it's women it's women yeah yeah i
think no i think it's
i always talk about confidence yeah
right like if you can re so you listen
everybody ha like you might have a puppy
and you're like i know what that puppy
wants i know wants food i want you know
some people have that same mentality
with animals at all like i can tell when
i get in with a tiger if it's going to
be chill and i know that like i can tell
before it's going to want to attack me
wind is going to do it and same thing
with reptiles i can just oh i can look
at a reptile at a zoo and be like okay
that needs a little bit more food it
means you know it's that's aggro that's
whatever the k you know so i think that
confidence and the ability to read them
and that could be something that's
natural i don't i don't know that you
can learn i mean you can learn like my
wife lori she wasn't a reptile person
she's learned to really deal with
reptiles but you know i i just i've
always been that way like i've always
been able to read like every animal and
maybe or maybe i'm just lucky i don't
know maybe i'm testing fate all the time
but i i um
you know you give me a challenge i'm in
for it when it comes it's part of that
it when it comes to being around
reptiles because it's just
i wouldn't think it was crazy if it
wasn't something that struck up so much
fear we had a blind lady that was on the
podcast one time
we're just talking about all kinds of
stuff what it's like to be blind and
different inquiries and blonde inquiries
and
she said the craziest thing we're
talking about animals she said the
craziest thing is snake she's like i get
nothing from a snake like other animals
i can hold i can feel i can get some
kind of energy from them but a snake i
just don't get anything from it
interesting and that's when i knew dawg
y'all was [ __ ] up bro you know what i
was saying that's what i knew you always
out there dark arts
i don't know so do you think that you
get a reading from snakes like do you
think it's a temptation to battle like
this
this this
thing that's so scary to other people
like is there any of that in it for you
yeah i think that
you know most people that are really
into reptiles there's a little bit of
like outlandish you know you want to be
a little bit of an outlaw like type of
thing i think that you're a little you
don't you know follow the same path as
everybody else there's no doubt about
that yeah the snake guy was always a
crazy guy yeah you know i mean that's
it's kind of cool to be the crazy guy in
a way yeah yeah but people always are
surprised how like i may do crazy things
but i'm not that crazy the snake guy was
always a really cool guy though yeah
yeah like you said you know when you
said earlier on like hey did what do you
think about the women i tell you what
guys with snakes always get the women
really yeah
i don't know what fascinates them i
don't know if because you're you're a
rebel you know i don't know what it is
but it seems like all my snake friends
are always hooking up with the hottest
chicks
do you feel like uh a lot of that snakes
that snakes know it's you if you have a
snake do you think a snake knows it's
you you know that's a tough question man
i think that we there's something that's
called anthropomorphism right when we
start you know applying our human uh
feelings to an animal right you know
people do it with everybody with their
dogs even they anthropomorphized yeah
yeah people start looking like they're
animals too they say all the time and
sometimes it's true yeah i agree with
you there i so i don't know you know i'd
like to there are certainly reptiles
that know me my reptile you know lizards
and and some other things like that and
you know they know you well yeah i mean
literally i have a rhino iguana that uh
her name is bella she'll only come to me
like when i call her she'll come to me
when i call her my crew she won't come
to you know so she's you know and a lot
a lot of my animals act very differently
with snakes they act different to me as
well but is i wonder sometimes is that
my like calmness with them that's making
them calm with me you know what i mean i
don't know that they read i just don't
know you can't read that with the snake
and if i said her and told you i i did i
think people think i was kooky
do you feel sometimes though like
there's some kind of connection like
sometimes i'll see an animal brawn i'll
be like dude there's some piece of me
inside of me that's also inside of that
animal do you feel that with snakes
sometimes because we're all come out of
nature yeah i mean i think we're all
connected right you know but i don't
think that i'm like part of a snake or
something i think uh but i do think that
you know we're all kind of
interconnected through energies and
stuff like that and um so i think that
that's that's what i always say you know
if you have
confidence you have like positive energy
you're less likely to get bit okay less
likely to get hurt you know it's when
you're afraid of stuff you know or even
like when you're catching a snake and i
had one of my crew out and we were uh in
florida and and like he wanted to catch
this little liz you know how little
lizards running around in florida all
the time and he's like oh let me go
catch this and he gets close and he
hesitates right yeah and then the lizard
runs away and i'm like you can't
hesitate you know it's just like you
play that guy in a movie i think yeah
honestly yeah that's me yeah no even
like with a crocodile like if you're
going to catch a crocodile the last i
mean you know again we're in a place
called josini africa and we were it
actually was crazy i was i was filming a
documentary and um we hook up with this
guy you know josini is the largest uh
population of of uh nile crocodiles in
one area in south
africa and it's it's yeah josini and uh
it's you know tons of big wild crocs and
so the biologist that had been studying
him for over a year was named mark right
and so my my fixtures for the the show
like hooked up with this guy like hey we
want to catch a croc we'll do some
research you know some skewed samples
whatever the case is toxicology stuff
and uh so we go out on this boat we get
there we go we only have a day and a
half right we go out on a boat and we
gotta catch a croc for this film right
we got the whole film crew with us stuff
like that we're like and he's like all
right this is what we're gonna do we got
this noose on the end of a pole we're
gonna try to you know get to the bank
they're all on the banks and and as they
come out new some and then we can pull
them over to land right and so you know
at one croc after another explodes in
the water gone explodes in the water
going
hours and hours and hours we aren't even
getting close right so finally i look
back to him and i go mark you know like
how many crocs have you caught dude he's
like and he's been there over a year
he's a biologist i mean crocodile
biology he's like well i've never caught
one i'm like what here we are with the
film crew we haven't caught one like
we're screwed right and so we had we had
a half a day the next day so i spent the
night like sleepless right like what am
i gonna do about this man you know and i
kind of devised a plan and literally we
went out the next morning and within an
hour we had a like a 15 foot bull
crocodile giant crocodile but my point
is that now you're pulling them on land
when you jump that thing right because
you got to jump them tape them and stuff
like that so you got a 15-foot bull
crockett let's put a bull crocodile oh
yeah yeah nile crocodile yeah right
there i mean oh there we go is that it
yeah there you go man there's that's
right there they're giant
yeah does one of those say bull
crocodile yeah it's just a male
crocodile you know so the the bull
crocodile the male crocodile is going to
be one of your bigger crocodiles in the
in in the in the area and they're all
hierarchy right the biggest one is the
bull because he's like hey i've got this
damn don't come around me i'm going to i
got all the women i want you can't have
that one of those spins can you pull it
up please
so that's one of them right there yeah i
mean is this the size of the yeah that's
actually smaller you put a dart on them
no we don't no no no nothing man we just
literally we knew some get them on land
and then that's what i'm saying no
hesitation right you have to jump it you
have to jump on top of it and get that
thing subdued so that someone can tape
its mouth so you can do your research on
it so how were you guys the one you guys
were able to get you guys what what was
the difference that you guys chose to do
that day so so basically what happened
was there was one area on the end of the
the dam that actually had some hippos on
there and and so the boat driver didn't
want to go over there right so what's
happened is when they were just
exploding the water they're just
disappearing on the opposite side of the
dam it was kind of shallow for about a
hundred feet so when they exploded off
the the the side they'd have to run
and and so i knew that if we could like
triangulate when hey let's get to where
they get to deep water now we got a
chance to know some right now the the
boat driver really really want to go
over there because of course hippos oh
they're dangerous
but i'm like that's the only chance we
have right and so we went out and like i
said there was a big 15 plus foot
crocodile and and we that's the one
right and i said and i remember a boat
driver's name was amos and i said amos
don't go towards the crocodile go where
he's gonna go right like when he's
exploding that way you gotta meet him at
that right when he gets that water right
and we got there got the noose on him
drug him across land it took six of us
to drag him out onto land because he was
so heavy and then i had to jump his head
right you know so you got to jump on top
of his head with your body what are you
wearing yeah i mean this right here you
know this i'm like i'm not no khakis no
hat
just me you know but no hesitation you
hesitate speakers though huh yes it was
yeah it was sneakers but man slip and
fall you're done you know but like i
said you hesitate that thing's going to
take your hand off your arm off you have
to be quick you have to make you have to
make your own move do you think they
respect it almost a little bit more or
they're just it's just surprised i think
it's surprised yeah i don't think they
care either way you know i mean they you
know listen crocodiles have one thing in
mind they they're predators man they're
apex predators 100 million years on this
planet you know so so when you say an
apex predator is a snake an apex
predator it can be depends on where it
is you know a lot of snakes aren't apex
apex predators would just mean that they
don't have a you know there's nobody
predate predates on them right really
most apex predators crocodiles uh you
know
the list goes on anything that would you
know lions tigers the only real
predators that they have are humans
really you know we're the only ones that
can kill them i mean in the wild if
humans weren't around nothing kills a
big crocodile right yeah so big
crocodiles are really there they don't
have anything getting them not well not
except for humans not anymore yeah not
anymore and now down in the everglades
you've got the burmese pythons that are
eating alligators which you know those
are both apex predators you know in asia
burmese python's 20 foot you know 18 20
foot pythons they're the apex predators
once they hit adulthood you know
nothing's killing those guys but now
you've got two of them down in florida
fighting for the same land you know and
where are these two located at do they
know
uh yeah they're down in the everglades
you know so how many are there a lot of
burmese pythons alive on the planet yeah
well just in in florida alone there
there's estimates of a couple hundred
thousand jesus christ yeah yeah and
those are those are not supposed to be
there man they're not supposed to be
sleep dog
you're making me scared bro
well i'm listen i'm gonna i'm we're
gonna go the other way we're gonna talk
about how awesome snakes are right i
don't know if we can make it there yeah
we can i don't know i didn't come here
to scare you theo i came here and did it
and that's it i i just think it's i'm
even an example of what i'm saying what
i was thinking about earlier it's like
ah it's like you have all this pin i
remember the first snake i ever saw was
walking with my grandparents and my
grandmother hated me and this freaking
snake went next you know wrapped around
my boot and i was so scared they're like
don't move and my grandmother was like
beating me in the leg with this shovel
and i'm like what is happening i
couldn't even see the snake i didn't
know what was going on i knew my
grandmother didn't like me
so i'm just like this i knew you know i
didn't think it was going to go down
like this we're in the woods i'm saying
i thought we're going fishing and now
i'm thinking that they're trying to take
my life you know
and then it's a black snake wrapped
around my uh
wrapped around my boot um
and then i remember being a kid swimming
in the uh
like the chocolate or bogo fellaire or
something and
with my friend robert and he had
he was like haunted or something he had
some kind of issue where
he would say stuff and then like he
would repeat everything he would say
over real quietly under his breath
he'd be like it's lunchtime
and he did it for everything you know so
i think he's supposed to be twins or
something you know i don't know what
happened to him but um anyway he and i
are out there playing right and he and
we just see this on top of the water
just
and we're just i mean it just so much
every time it was always fear i think i
never knew anybody who introduced me to
a snake as a hey this is a safe thing
around this is a safe thing yeah so it
was always a lot of fear in in the
environment of snakes so i think i
that's what i think i am as an example
that people show up with to you with all
that [ __ ] like hey you did it yeah you
know you did it brian
yeah you know like you put those things
in my childhood you [ __ ] yeah like i
think there's a lot of that because it's
such a fear thing for a lot of people or
for me anyway yeah well you know what
the opposite of fear is is knowledge
right so the more you know the less you
fear right so yeah you know when your
grandma was beating you all you thought
of is bad snake right yeah not bad
grandma but bad snake
yeah i probably thought a little bit of
both about my grandma my grandmother was
really she was a real she was out there
but but yeah i think yeah you yeah a lot
of stuff gets yeah it's just such a fear
thing you know yeah so and there's not a
lot and especially there anything used
to be there wasn't a we didn't have
snakes in the classroom really yeah we
didn't we had one fella named curtis
oh i'll tell you it is dude so
we went to prom or something some dance
sadie hawkins or something we got to
wear the same shirt right yeah
and my buddy ended up touching this
girl's crotch for like the first time
ever in our childhood i don't know if
it's appropriate i know your son's in
here but yeah um is it okay he's touched
i'm not gonna say
okay good yeah and it's safe it's a
human crotch you know nothing insane
but um
and my buddy's dad comes out there by
the fire and is like
spends the whole night like like
basically massaging my buddy's hand that
he touched the girl's crotch with like
real dark stuff going on
so anyway that night we have to sleep at
my buddy's house right and he had like
15 snakes in his room wow in cages and
dude i'd never
i've never knowingly slept within
probably almost 50 miles of a snake
because that's where the zoo was closest
to us
and i remember he turned this i'm laying
there off to sleep in his bed
i'm laying there and he turns the
ceiling fan and he had the fastest
ceiling fan i've ever heard in my life
so suddenly every snake i feel like is
just wide awake every snake smell is
just swirling in the room and i'm just
laying there in this cauldron of just
like hopelessness
you know it had just been such an insane
night
and uh
and then my friend's dog barked outside
the dad went out shot the dog in the
head right mr joe
but anyway uh but anyway so that was
just another scary night where i'm
surrounded by snakes you know yeah so
trauma yeah i've just had a lot of
trauma with snakes man um ptsd i do i
think i do have ptsd yeah now you got a
snake showing up in your living room or
whatever you know yeah i do man we got a
question that came in right here
actually from a gentleman i think what
is this
hey what's up brian what's up theo um
my name is geo
nice to meet you
uh i got a question for brian regarding
reptiles snakes things of that nature
nature itself
um
you feel like they're what's like the
biggest misconception you feel
that
most people have about snakes venomous
or
nonvenomous and uh or reptiles in
general that you
feel like you'd like to squash right now
you just you just want to set the record
straight for the world the u.s and other
places
and theo not to make things a little
awkward
but do you think that brian is in
cahoots with bobby lee and that's how
you got that snake
i'd say you got that little snake in
your in your hotel that you posted on
your story yeah it's a thought not to
make it awkward or whatever but
just think think about it
all right thank you for your service mr
gonzalez that's a good question uh
that's two good questions let's start
with the first one what is a
misconception man because i feel
misconceived yeah totally yeah that
they're killers you know that they're
they're you know like just cold-blooded
killers that all they want to do they're
put here to hurt you you know which is
just not the case you know as a matter
of fact why do you think a rattlesnake
has a rattle to tell you to stay away
from it right it doesn't want to bite
you yeah you know so that's a huge
misconception that snakes are just
heartless killers and that they're here
to hurt you what are they here to do
they're here really they're here to
be part of the ecosystem right so you
know like think about a farmer right a
farmer that has
you know
mice like grain right so now there's
mice in the fields well those snakes are
there to kill the mice to save your
grain right yeah you know it's happened
before where like you know maybe a kid
gets bit into town by rattlesnake then
they go and they kill all the
rattlesnakes all of them and then they
lose their crop to infantation
infestation of rodents right i see so
it's a real equalizer it is it's if
they're here to equalize everything a
huge huge huge part of the ecosystem and
uh one that if you take it away you're
in big trouble really yeah big trouble
so when why don't do snakes operate
mostly at night are they nighttime
workers they can be both you know they
can be both so basically how you would
tell a nocturnal animal from a diurnal
animal daytime nighttime is uh round
pupils
daytime uh slits like cat eyes nighttime
the one you had was actually a diurnal
moving around in the daytime it's
daytime daytime okay
um
and then i don't know bobby lee you know
so i i i'm not gonna take any if there's
one ethnicity you had to guess let's
ballpark it
and let's say asian
that would send someone a snake what
what ethnicity is most associated with
snakes throughout the history of time oh
my goodness that's great you know i
that's wow you know like obviously
ancient egyptians were really into it uh
indians i mean you know you have in
india you have people you know kids that
are raised to be snake people
from the time they're infants you know
like around snakes they're they're some
of the most adept snake people you know
i think those two cultures are really
really you know japan again they they
worship a lot of snakes they have
temples snake temples and stuff like
that yeah so i think all those things
you know and then um yeah so i think
probably egyptian
indian japanese would be my two they're
my three top ones egyptian indian
japanese bobby lee
yeah interesting yeah very interesting
uh
well he admitted to sending me the snake
so that's the crazy part
yeah he has an episode of his podcast
coming out in like a couple days that he
admitted to sending me the snake he sent
it huh so it's just insane i feel like
and how do you even get a snake through
the mail can you mail a snake to someone
what are the legal u.s postal system
rules about a snake or fedex you can't
mail it but you can fedex it
so i could send it fedex to your door
but you can't mail it that's i think
that why is the mail or the postal
people are they more afraid of it or
what is it's the
where it's just a rule that they have i
think that if i'm not mistaken and i
could be wrong about it but i think you
can ship frogs weirdly enough you know
through the mail uh but you can't do
reptiles but uh but fedex ups you know
chances are if you're flying on a plane
there's a reptile in that the belly of
that plane
or tarantulas there's probably just
think about that next time you're
sitting up there having a cocktail no i
don't want to do that okay
i mean i respect you for want me to but
i just i don't know if that's gonna help
me man it's been hard for me to sleep
since i saw that snake in my house
really yeah yeah we gotta work on you
that man we gotta get you over it yeah i
do need to man um
the last thing you wanna do is look
hellish
in your
clothing the last thing you want to do
is see somebody wearing they we they're
wearing a
a tank top and a uh condom you know what
i'm saying in a hat
you got to look good
yup
that's why you need to check out public
wreck
they make elevated
athleisure wear
in multi-dimensional sizes because they
believe that comfort starts with a
better fit
man there's nothing i like more than
having a style that can look like i
could be in the gym and then i could
also be in a meeting with jim who's jim
he owns the company okay
it's a fabric unlike any other public
wreck
spent years engineering the perfect
blend of softness damn you love children
come over and pet you and try to feed
you a cup of corn that's how soffit damn
is
stretch and durability
all the performance benefits everything
you love
these are always the top choice in my
rotation public wreck
they rarely discount anything but right
now they have an exclusive offer just
for
tpw listeners go to public rec that's
public
rec dot com use promo code theo to
receive 10 percent off
that's public rec
public rec dot com use our promo code
theo for 10 off
at least go check out what they have
you're gonna like it
look it's tough when you're looking for
insurance online it's aggravating you
don't want to do it
it feels overwhelming a lot of times it
feels like too much
that's what i've noticed
well times have changed
and thanks to the zebra
the zebra
it's that striped sneaky prison looking
animal
yup you can compare car and home
insurance quotes from every major
insurance company in under five minutes
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision in fact the
zebra saves people an average of 922
dollars a year on home and auto combined
it's a lot of money it's an extra g
get yourself a swing set or get
something for the children
get a teeter totter for your daddy
yep the zebras help me it can help you
compare quotes for free at the zebra.com
t-h-e-o and support the podcast that's
at the zebra.com
slash theo save time and money in
minutes on your home and auto insurance
if someone sees a snake in the house
thankfully there's a lipscomb university
here not far from here and the soccer
coach
his wife uh
saw that i had a snake in my house and
he came over because i guess soccer
they're running around after all the
time people somebody gets bit probably
every couple days
because they're in a big field you know
yeah but um
so anyway he came over and helped me get
rid of it uh
so that was pretty cool but
um
but yeah what do you do then because now
i'm like thinking i need to get trapped
i need to make sure there's no more
snakes in my house like
um that's where a lot of my fear is at
now you know and my concern really no
i'm sure it's just a one-off thing you
know i mean number one snakes don't
really like den and infest places you
know that really really happens so so
it's they're pretty solitary animals and
that i saw the snake that was in your
house it's just a rat snake and it was
like you know probably a year old
something like that so there's no
brothers and sisters hanging out you
know waiting for you around the corner
so i think you're pretty safe here
pretty good and as far as what to do you
know i mean thankfully in this area you
know
you know you just call somebody that
local pet shop or something like that
they send someone over and pick it up
you know there are actual snake catchers
in africa in australia that that's their
full-time job is just to go and you know
get snakes out that i've done that in
africa with snake catchers go out and
remove mambas from
literally a shanty shed this size where
it's like you know someone wakes up and
there's a mamba in their their ceiling
you know and and we're talking a room
this size that it's dangerous man you
know there's nowhere in the room that
you can't get bit when that snake is
around you know i mean it's got that
strike range so so there's literally
people that that's what they do for a
living is just remove snakes and protect
people but in this country we don't have
that problem
in this country can you die from a snake
bite
it's pretty rare i mean anyone can die
you know you've got diamond backs you've
got uh you know quite you know pygmy
rattlesnakes you've got you know lots of
rattlesnakes mainly in this country also
have coral snakes but actual death rate
in this country is pretty low because of
treatment right um if you get bit you
get to a hospital you get treatment it's
not going to be pretty you know
depending on how bad the bite is but um
but you're gonna you're gonna live you
know or and yeah it was is any person
more likely to get bit by a snake like
if you're wearing jewelry if you are
caucasian if you are
um russian if you are
uh mexican if you are black if you are
uh
wearing like a costume or something is
there anybody more likely to get bit i
would say the most likely person to get
bit really the most most likely is
someone that keeps them as a pet
second would be
someone that's drinking comes across a
rattlesnake in the wild and wants to
cowboy and like look at me i can get the
rattlesnake you know they've seen steve
irwin whatever the case is down the road
and they're like i'm gonna do this
uh that is a bug of some sort okay yeah
that's not a reptile
damn yeah that no that i'd be more
afraid of than a reptile oh yeah we got
that in here yeah yeah yeah but uh yeah
those are you know usually alcohol has a
lot to do with uh getting people getting
bit yeah alcohol a lot of times so
there's no real ethnicity or skin tone
or anything do you notice that native
americans have good relationships with
snakes uh
i wouldn't say so i i have my family as
native american oh really they like it
they like them you know but uh uh i
wouldn't say they're any better or worse
off for it at least the ones in my
family but they do fine
wow that's interesting because i would
feel like they would have a whole
different like just a different history
with them you know because they have
more experience probably being around
them yeah i think that's another thing
we're just so not innate or not in that
as much nature as we used to be right
you know and so we see less snakes um
no that's true especially i was in
california for a long time so we never
saw a snake there really yeah i never
saw anything in california unless it was
already had one
um
well that was about it yeah you get out
in the deserts and around la and there
there's a lot of rattlesnakes you know i
mean it's it's not far away from the
city too trust me i mean you're right
outside the city and you're you're
getting rattlesnakes and gopher snakes i
mean it's there's a lot out there i've
i've caught a bunch of snakes out in
california in the la area so you're
growing up you got the f you got the big
you got the mo you got the money from
selling the snakes what size snakes are
you selling big babies are you selling
eggs what do you do yeah i sell i used
to sell babies you know that's how i
started you know and it was uh i sold
babies of snakes that were gonna get 18
foot i sold babies snakes that were
gonna get five foot you know uh now i
don't do big snakes i i we do still
breed some stuff but mainly i'm an
education zoo film stuff like that you
know i'm not into the big breeder world
like i used to be but uh um but that's
how it came up because that was the only
way listen you know i just wanted to
work with reptiles i didn't know you
know and breeding reptiles was the best
way for me to do it right i could get a
job at the zoo but there's not much
money there and there's not many
openings you know so uh so yeah so i
worked with reptiles i bred reptiles
because that was the the way i could you
know it's the labor of love you know
what's the funnest reptile to breed oh
my gosh uh i think it you know like live
bearer ones you know because you know
snakes can have eggs and they can have
live right and when you just like wait
really yeah like rattlesnakes have live
right so they just have a baby come
right out yeah i just boom we're live as
a matter of fact crazy story just
recently i had what i thought was a pair
of anacondas i have a giant female
anaconda like i'm talking like you know
125 pound anaconda and then i had now
males are they're what they call
sexually dimorphic so males are smaller
so i was sold this animal's male my
mistake didn't sex it and so i'm like
yeah they're not breathing that's kind
of weird this is literally like a month
month and a half ago and one day uh i
come in and the male is uh now that's
never been in with a male by the way the
this is these two animals have been
together that's it uh has a virgin baby
it's by itself by itself because it have
both
it's no it didn't have both genitalia
it's what they call parthenogenesis so
it's it's only a female it's like a
virgin birth no sperm no anything and
it's actually a clone of its itself no
way yeah so my male turned into a female
and had a virgin birth so do they use
that type of information to try and
learn more about human cloning and stuff
like i mean that seems like a real yeah
they should i don't think i don't know
if they are i mean maybe someone out
there is i don't know no one ever
contacted me to say hey can we do some
research on it would be cool though i'd
love to see it but but yeah i mean
genetically there's no male you know
there's only one side and there's
actually there are reptile species like
morning geckos a little lizard right
that have no males in the entire species
everyone's females
isn't that crazy i mean so and they
produce like so parthenogenesis in
let's say an anaconda is rare like very
rare like there's probably only been a
handful of recorded cases ever but then
there's morning geckos that that's all
they have is partner genesis but i'd say
my going back to your point is live
babies are always the funnest so that's
really the power in nature i mean nature
when the when
when put up against the wall can just
make its own
self yeah it's like the jurassic park
thing right nature finds a way can other
animals do that too
uh i don't think mammals there's ever
been a parthenogenic mammal can you look
at it yeah yeah yeah parthenogenesis
mammal yeah jesus yeah jesus yeah jesus
is the first snake
you said it not me i mean i i i never
felt his skin but i would he doesn't
seem like it yeah
what do we say here there are
known cases
of naturally occurring
melee membrane alien parthenogenesis in
the world in the wild
so yeah so it didn't happen
of mammals what does progeny mean
offspring
parthenogenic offspring of mammals would
have two x chromosomes and would
therefore be female in 1935 george
growing reportedly successfully
wow into a rabbit reported successfully
inducing parthenogenesis in a rabbit wow
i wonder how he would induce
parthenogenesis in a rabbit
i don't know i don't know i don't know
how that goes that's wild i mean that
guy i'd like to have a beer with that
guy yeah i'd like to freaking make sure
his daughter's okay yeah
um
damn that's intense man wow
so that's what one thing that baffles me
a lot man is just the ability of nature
you know especially we get so like
citified and comfortable and like
so used to like uh human accoutrements
and stuff
now we forget sometimes how much of
nature we are yeah at least i do anyway
yeah i love getting out man you got to
get away and especially when you're in
the bush for a while like you get out
you know like just totally away from
everything it's amazing how quick you
adapt right the first couple days when
you're away from everything like cell
phones and internet and tv and stuff
like that it's a little bit weird right
because we're so used to that like oh
god check instagram you know and uh a
couple days it's a little weird but then
also you just kind of forget about it
you know and it's it's wild how quickly
you can acclimate into a situation
because there's been times where i've
been out for 30 40 days you know where
there's like nothing you know i mean
you're just in the bush you know working
and it's actually amazing and then when
you come back to reality
it feels really weird you know i mean
like you know you turn on the tv yeah
it's almost like over sense you know
like oh that's that's bizarre it feels
almost bad yeah it does it really does
you know i mean i look at my screen time
on my phone all the time i'm like damn i
spent two hours on my phone today you
know yeah just this week man i'm trying
to really back off
i'm trying to really really back off
make things less important if i can
here's a question right here from a
young man that seems rather interesting
brian theo
what's up boys
uh stoked to see brian on the podcast
i've always been a big fan of you know
reptiles and all things
wild if you will um
i guess my question is for brian what
are your thoughts on the existence of a
giant anaconda
still being out there
lurking in the depths of the amazon or
venezuela or wherever those things would
be
um
yeah
guess it's kind of cryptozoological if
you will but i figured i'd just throw it
out there peace theo see you in
charleston man oh excellent i'll see you
soon what about that moby dick out there
is there something out there going on
listen um
theodore roosevelt
or teddy roosevelt i'm sorry uh when he
was president put out a grant for 50 000
for anyone that could come up with a
snake over 30 foot live or dead right
way back then and and then it ultimately
ended up i think getting raised to like
75 000
until the 90s when they discontinued the
the grand and then recently i even put
out something saying i'd give someone a
hundred grand they came up with a
30-foot snake i would prefer live
instead of dead but uh and no one's ever
claimed that prize so so is there a
snake out there in venezuela by the way
he had a cool shirt on um that's
possible i mean you know is there
megalodon probably not you know but i'm
not gonna say never right you know do
you think nature could be trying to run
it back ever do you ever get that sense
being out in nature a lot and seeing a
lot of these animals like on ground zero
of like uh
like some of these genetic sequences
messing with these baby animals do you
ever uh think that nature could be
trying to run it back and get more
dinosaurs out here man i tell you what i
mean you know listen it's possible
there's a lot of land out there that no
one has ever you know the animals are
being discovered all the time right you
know i think it was in the early 2000s
there was a a an ape like a 200 pound
ape that was discovered in vietnam that
no one it was like a mythical lore for
200 years and i was like no there's no
that's not true and then they found that
it was real you know so is it possible
yeah i mean i think it's possible
coelacanths you know a fish you know
with silicate i've never seen them so if
you ever uh
yeah coelacanth um these were thought to
be extinct for two for 100 million years
and now they've found them multiple
times so is it possible there's like
some dinosaur out there heck yeah that's
possible is it likely you know this is
what i always tell people when someone
says hey do you believe in this i say i
want to believe
but i don't i don't know you know i mean
i don't know it's never been found you
know i would love titanoboa to still be
around a 50-foot snake you know maybe
one's crawling around there most likely
not right just like megalodon's probably
not a megalodon in the water right but
we don't know what about lots uh loch
ness monsters is when you ever see that
did you believe it or not
same i'll say the same thing i want to
believe do i think there's a loch ness
monster no i don't but i want to believe
because it'd be badass right could you
imagine if uh you know plesiosaur would
get found in loch ness that'd be
absolutely amazing but uh but i i don't
think so i don't think so i'm i'm a
pretty realistic guy until i have proof
and i'm a science guy so you got to show
me before as much as i want my heart to
believe in it until i see it i can't
believe it
who was your first girlfriend was it
your wife or no oh no no i had i was
dated around a little yeah a little bit
yeah a little bit a little little and
would you messing with snakes then would
you bring would you bring a snake on a
date would you bring a date to a snake
uh not to be honest with you i didn't uh
do that much would you keep them
separate ever at that age were you like
kind of scared that girl yeah this is
scary yeah i think i think especially
when i was like 15 16 you know i was
kind of a rock or played in a band you
know i had some groupie girlfriend stuff
like that yeah i didn't want them to
think i was that much of a freak you
know especially back then like i said it
was so you know you know you were like i
don't want to lose this so yeah each
town had one snake dude or every other
town had a snake dude like that's kind
of
yeah i remember it being like oh you
hear like oh that's the snake dude and
we were like what yeah and then he'd
like hi he'd scurry off or something
yeah i wasn't that guy but but uh yeah i
was you know to be honest with like in
high school the last few years of high
school like people thought it was cool
right they're like oh man he keeps
snakes you know he plays in a rock band
i mean you know it's like people dug it
you know i mean i was friends with that
you know the jocks to the the the nerds
i was friends with everyone because i
okay kind of a little of everything in
me right i was into science i was you
know i still like to you know sports and
and i you know played rock music and i
kept snakes it's kind of like a little
bit for everybody
um
who was your first kiss do you remember
that growing up uh yeah karina was her
name i think i was about 11 years old
believe it or not i was a pretty young
starter no i take that back i take that
back uh i was eight years old named
helen helen police was her name this
sounds illegal yeah
i think she was like 14.
yeah yeah yeah so half my friends have
been busted for this kind of stuff yeah
it was
yeah and and if if memory serves me
correct it was a little more than a kiss
but
yeah
first yeah yeah
at eight years old what more is it a
kiss would have sunk me in the damn mud
dude yeah yeah a kiss would turn my
knees in the damn quicksand knees bruh
yeah right i couldn't even imagine
anything more at eight years old dude my
god
that's wild man um
so whenever you met your wife when you
first met her did you know it was gonna
be your wife or no dude this is it's a
funny story man i swear and this is a
honestly got truth uh i met her on her
18th birthday at a party and she was one
of my best friend's girlfriend's
girlfriend okay i met her i went home
that night and i told my mom i met the
girl i want to marry wow and and then so
then my friend i was like hey i gotta
meet meet up with laurie have a date you
know because we hung out a little bit
not too much you know for maybe a half
hour just talked and stuff like that so
the next day i called my friend like i
got to go on a date with this lori can
you hook me up you know and stuff like
that so uh so kathy my friend uh said uh
yeah sure called laurie she didn't even
remember meeting me no yeah so i met the
girl i wanted to marry she didn't even
remember meeting me
literally was like what i don't even
remember this guy i don't remember the
guy staring at you for four hours yeah
yeah long-haired guy you know i was the
only longer guy at the party you know i
mean yeah didn't even remember me didn't
even remember me but uh the guy with the
[ __ ] rango shirt on yeah exactly but
hey man it worked out you know she uh
she eventually came around and we've
been together ever since dude that's a
real comeback story right there i feel
like i think that's a total comeback
story guys you got to hear that man
yeah
zeroed in on a girl all night she had no
idea
that he even existed yeah no not at all
i could have been like yeah that's cool
i mean it's cool because a lot of a lot
of guys that'll shut us down right from
the beginning you know yeah you got to
be persistent but not a stalker yeah you
don't want to be a stalker you know i
mean just like you know and we were
friend zoned for a little while i was
like all right you know she's great must
be a friend for a little bit you know
great and uh and then that then next
thing you know we're together for 33
years so did you have children were they
live or were they egg when you had them
uh both both were live live born what we
call a ova viviparius oh really yeah
okay yeah
yeah and uh thanks you had two live
children and you got a boy and a girl or
would you get yeah boy and a girl girl
came first matter of fact i'm going to
be a grandpa this january
the first time yep so i got it rats dude
you look so young
thank you i appreciate it yep i'll be uh
a energenic grandpa hopefully uh raise
another generation of reptile loving
people so spread that love you know are
they all wrap lovers but you have right
now your family no to be totally honest
with you it's it's weird my son uh works
with us uh my daughter uh worked with us
out of like like she had to right when
she was younger but when she graduated
college she was really and you know like
hey listen i just want to tell you right
now i'm never working for you i'm going
off and doing my own thing and she got
like corporate job stuff like that so i
wouldn't say anyone's like overly like
rep like i'm a reptile nut right like
there's not probably i mean there's
probably two days out of a year that i'm
not around a reptile right like i'm
always around a reptile or an animal you
know sometimes it's not a reptile maybe
i'm around you know whatever i mean you
know lions or whatever but i'm always
around animals whereas uh you know my no
one in my family has that gene where i'm
just obsessed you know they tolerate it
you know my wife works because that's
what she does and she's she's learned to
like love the animals but she she's not
like listen i always say like if
tomorrow i was like we never have to see
a reptile again she's not going to cry
right yeah she'll be like okay that's
good let's move on
yeah
here's a question that came in right
here from some good gentleman right here
this is right i think
hey guys it's roy here from kansas
i was excited when i saw you guys were
doing a podcast together because i
watched both of you pretty religiously
uh theo i wanted to know what advice you
have for brian's son noah i don't know
if he's going to be on the podcast or
not but i know he's been trying to do
some a little bit of stand up locally
where they live
what advice would you give him
as a
amateur to maybe make it in the big
leagues one day
also i wanted to tell brian
i successfully hatched my first two
clutches of ball pythons this year or
last year i guess i'm getting ready to
pair up
all the females again this year okay and
uh probably have about six clutches this
year so
anyway
gang gang thank you voldemort look at
that yeah
advice what do you got you know that is
a good question man thank you for the
question roy man i appreciate you paying
attention to myself and brian that's
cool man it's interesting what kind of
people would pay attention to you and me
yeah you know that's real interesting
i'm sure there's a lot of crossover i'm
sure there is yeah you know i i i find
it interesting now you'll partner up
with people like okay
what is happening you know
um
i would say for know who is here by the
way good to see you noah
um
i would say
i even think in the beginning dude i
used to tell jim gaffigan's jokes right
what yeah i told this to jim gafkin why
he was on one time i said look dude i
just want to apologize to you i didn't
have any jokes in the beginning i just
used to tell your jokes right pocket i
did the hot pocket thing oh yeah i told
a couple of them yeah yeah it was good i
think i even sold t-shirts based on one
of his jokes one time so i would tell
the joke and then sell his shirt after
the show yeah but what it did for me was
it just got me used to telling jokes on
stage i had plans to tell my own jokes
and i had saw my own jokes peppered in
there yeah um
but it just got me comfortable
telling jokes sure
so it was like it wasn't anything that
was being recorded or anything like that
so it just got me like
how do i learn to get whatever some of
this comfort is sure and then i think
one benefit that noah probably has is
that your dad is a unique character
right
my dad was a unique character my dad was
70 when i was born everybody knows that
so like
it just gave me a lot of material it was
like you know it gave me a lot of like
cute kind of little jokes that were safe
that were pretty clean yeah uh that i
could tell about my dad you know um
and so i think i always felt like that
was kind of a blessing like i was always
angry that my dad not angry but it was
always felt odd you know kids always
want to be just the regular kids always
want to be like sure you know nothing
that stands out real crazy sure you know
your dad comes to show-and-tell and he's
a [ __ ] guy out there who's doing
magic or something you know i'm saying
that kid
is probably going to get beaten down
right but it's like so i think if your
dad comes and your dad comes to show and
telling he's like i was born in 1910 you
know that's a weird time for the class
yes um
so i think it could there's just a lot
of unique material when your dad is
unique like you are so i think that
that's i would play on just easy stuff
in the beginning yeah um so those are
things that i think are just probably
gifts that are in your wheelhouse yeah
yeah when you come from a fan i mean
there's a lot of stories right i mean
you know my mom and dad are you know
have a reptile zoo we travel all over
the world we do crazy stuff been on
discovery channel we open uh you know
yeah there's a lot of material there
yeah it's a weird it's a weird life
right you know i say that all the time i
mean like i've lived a huge the craziest
life ever you know i mean it's the
weirdest thing like i literally clean
snake [ __ ] for a living you know what i
mean it's like it's the weirdest thing
but yet i get to do the most amazing
things on the planet you know it's like
you know most people look at me and like
how did this happen i'm like i don't
even know how it happened you know like
i don't even know how i got here you
know i'm sitting in theo vaughn's
podcast room here you know it's crazy
right yeah it is i mean it's definitely
interesting um
yeah i'm trying to think of some more
and more of my curiosities about snakes
so snakes um
why do snakes eat rats and stuff like
that well most most of them eat rats or
rabbits or pigs or whatever the case may
be they're just carnivores right you
know but there are snakes that eat
really weird things like snails some
would eat worms some will only eat slugs
other snakes eat only other snake or
mainly other snakes like king cobras eat
mainly other snakes you know in the wild
so uh so they're a very diverse animal
right you know but in captivity most you
know most snakes that that people keep
are mice and rats you know do snakes
ever do anything fun together you think
no no i don't think so they're pretty
solitary animals we keep most of our
snakes separate and it's except for
breeding i think they just want to be
left alone you know i think they're not
like a
real social animal although there's like
the narcissist snake dens if you want to
pull that up it's pretty cool garcia
snake den up in manitoba canada it's
crazy it's the place you would love to
go i'm sure with you and is it outdoors
or it's in indoors it's outdoors and so
it's a natural occurring naturally
occurring snake den that is this is your
nightmare right here dude oh
i mean thousands and thousands of snakes
gathered together
yeah thousands and thousands of snakes
but but it's crazy i mean it's like uh
it's a super popular tourism place you
know people go and see these thousands
of snakes that have den together for
hibernation or brewmation is what they
would call it and uh pretty crazy right
damn i've never been i want to go huh i
want to go so bad you know i've never
seen anything like it but i want to
check it out it's like burning man
yeah burning man for snakes right
exactly it's like berm
yeah
it's like burning man and how much
snakes are there and what are they why
are they there again well they're just
broomating so so a lot of times in
particular species like garter snakes
will brew mate together
uh so they're mating they're not even
mating no they're just like going to
sleep for like a hibernation first okay
a foreign they just sleep in a group and
then they wake up and then when they
wake up they then they get into breeding
and you'll have like breeding modes and
stuff like that and then uh yeah i mean
that's that's pretty much it you know
and then then they'll go on their own
way you know during the summer months
they're not together at all have a snake
ever eaten an animal and then the animal
lived and cut open the snake and got out
well i don't know of any of that have
lived but there have been like there's
actually a famous picture you can pull
this up too and alex burmese python eats
alligator and explodes out of the uh so
the the alligator explodes out of the
burmese python what the [ __ ] are you all
doing dude
oh my god i'm sure
well you're gonna have to clear your
cash when you're when we're done here
around here
i mean y'all gotta chill with all of
this [ __ ] right so you can see the
second picture here right over here not
that one the neck that one right there
that's actually an alligator that's
busting out of a snake's gun you know
stomach
so
yeah it's crazy right
nature man it's awesome
it [ __ ] scares me so much man i think
that's the thing that scares me
sometimes about dying is going back and
becoming part of something that i'm
scared of right yeah you could be a
snake who knows man or even it's a part
you know being becoming like a cell and
a snake it really does that's the thing
i think that scares me the most about
them is like
is that they are closer to whatever the
source of like life is that i i feel
like then
you've evolved that way but maybe maybe
and i'm no expert in this buddhism or
whatever but maybe you you keep moving
forward not backwards yeah the next life
you're supposed to be one step closer to
the enlightenment right yeah no you
could be right no no i think you're
right
i think that it's like but i just wonder
which way is the enlightenment going
it's like i don't know what the scale is
yeah you think you start off at the
beginning and then end up a single cell
amoeba somewhere yeah like that's what i
don't know it's like i don't know which
way yeah and which way you're passing
like are you headed this way or you just
whatever you did in this turn in this uh
you know this space in the firmament
does that choose wherever you're going
to be at next kind of um
yeah i choose to think that it'll be
better
next time yeah if there's a next time
that's a really good outlook i think um
i'm an optimist are you yeah you seem
like an optimist man yeah it's gonna be
really nice you're not i would like to
be i think i think i am i just think i'm
just like a burnt out optimist gotcha
not even drug induced just like
oh god
been so yeah i've been thinking
optimistic for so long i'm tired of
thinking yeah anymore yeah i understood
and you're always battling the dark arts
i feel like right so you're like man you
want to see more of the light you know
yeah i think that's one thing that's
neat about
what's one thing that's neat about life
in general is if you get off of like a
lot of like the news and the bs and
twitter and a lot of that you get back
to the things that are more important
and yeah there is a lot of joy and a lot
more optimism yeah i don't i don't watch
the news man i i like boycotted it yeah
about two years ago i was like i'm done
don't get that in my life anymore just
you know negativity breeds negativity
man yeah it's like that i just want
get rid of all the negative stuff in my
life get you know surround myself with
positivity you know
and that's the thing that's nice about
animals right i mean they you get what
you give right you give them good you
know it's like a dog right if you love
your dog he's gonna love you back you
know and it's the same thing with
reptiles and and all animals for that
matter is there a reptile that you feel
i mean you mentioned that lizard that
can love you kind of yeah oh my gosh
yeah i mean it's crazy uh i you know and
i don't know if love is the right term
for a reptile i don't know what they're
thinking i have no idea uh but but they
definitely seem to have this you know
some seem to have this really
interesting bond where you know like i
have a giant anaconda the one i was
talking not the one that had the virgin
birth but the other female that uh you
know you go on her cage and she'll crawl
right up to you and just like sniff you
like a dog you know and i mean i've had
like other reptile people that have been
working with reptiles for decades come
and sit in the cage and they're like i
can't believe this this doesn't even
make sense to me because it's like you
would think that snake wants to go away
from you she actually literally wants to
come over to you and sniff you and
literally she'll
as soon as you go in here and close it's
a gigantic enclosure it's 10 and a half
by 10 octagon waterfall the whole shot
and um and and you know she loves to be
in the water you go in the water she'll
be right in there
swirling around your legs i mean yeah so
i think they they at least have a bond
if i don't know if it's love but it's a
bond for sure
do people ever rent snakes out from you
do you do like snake rentals you know i
don't rent snakes but we've worked with
we've done a few
things with like film and stuff like
that we're like hey can you bring a
snake for the day or something on that
line um i've been detroit has kid rock
ever rented a snake from you i you know
i haven't met kid rock uh met eminem uh
at an animal show i was doing once uh
kid rocket we just haven't crossed paths
you know my tattoo or tattoos him so oh
it's interesting that we haven't crossed
past some at some point but i would
think he would be into reptiles seems
like a guy that would be into reptiles
but we just haven't crossed paths but uh
but i do have people that their main job
is to rent snakes uh to to like movies
and stuff like that commercials but i
just don't i just don't do that you know
it's something i i probably could do
more if i wanna do but i don't care
about it that much was there a lot of
sacrifice because if you did so much
stuff it seems like with the animals was
it hard to like run a family and have
that at the same time or was things
pretty manageable did it all seem okay
no yeah dude you know i mean you know
just like in your career man when you're
committed you're committed now i've
suddenly you know with you you're
probably working constantly traveling
doing all these other engagements i'm
taking care of thousands of animals
right you know so and they don't take
christmas off right they don't have a
holiday you know so christmas morning we
are opening presents with the kids and
then i'm off to the shop to make sure
everything's healthy and happy and uh so
tons of sacrifice you know i mean you
know running businesses are sacrificed
yeah and then a live animal business is
even a giant sacrifice you know because
you're always uh and then you on my end
i because i film every day you know for
my vlog and now i got that i have to do
every day so yeah it's a it's the
balance is tough you know have you ever
got a crazy call somebody hit a snake or
this cops or need a snake or something a
man been hiding a snake something's
going on
you ever get called in because they're
like oh we know a guy yeah yeah i mean
i've i've been called into uh as a
matter of fact the real estate agent
just two days ago called me and said
that there was a snake in a house she
was renting similar to what happened to
you and said can you come by get the
snake i don't know what to do so we get
calls like that or or like the local
authorities will call us if they you
know maybe someone moved out of a house
and left snakes behind or reptiles
behind or or stuff like that we so we
will do that you know it's not something
that i you know it's part of my life or
something like that but i'm happy to
help at any point i can you know but
it's always weird i put out about
probably 20 pounds of snake repellent
this morning that smells like cinnamon i
thought so that's an interesting thing
right it's like i i heard you say that
and and you're right you know like
cinnamon is one pepper is another one
that people talk about i don't think any
of them work to be honest with you i
think it makes you feel better right i
mean not that i'm now i'm fake making
you feel worse but uh i i'm not sure
that that anything breaks the thing but
i i if i was a betting man i think your
uh invasion is over and you're not going
to see a snake again
is it worth setting any kind of trap
inside or anything like that to see if
there's more snakes in there would they
come and get it like a mousetrap or
something no no no no not really i think
there was a guy one time made uh this
snake uh trap thing that supposedly
worked so first off snakes oftentimes
want to be along a wall like they don't
want to be in the middle of the floor
because that's dangerous right you know
danger danger i'm in the middle of ever
so they'll like be along the walls right
and so he actually took like a a two
liter pepsi bottle that was an opening
that it could get into and put like a
little mouse in there and it could get
into it but then wasn't smart enough to
figure out how to get out of it
interesting you know so that was the
only snake trap i've ever seen that
apparently worked but i've never tried
it and and uh you know we don't get many
snake escapes but we get the occasional
snake that escapes you know from a
drawer or something like that and uh and
then we have to try to find it
probably you know i actually had a
19-foot snake escape once but that was
my fault i left it listen every time the
snakes escape it's always my fault i've
always accidentally left a latch on gun
or a lock undone and but uh and she
wasn't a happy snake either so it was a
lot of fun catching her have a snake
ever killed its owner that you know of
uh they have yeah yeah they have it's
not it's not common but it does happen i
think there's been about there's
probably been about five or six deaths
in the united states in the last 30
years oh that's not that many so it's
not many it's not many it's it's far
less than even shark attacks you know so
it's pretty no no you know again it
happens
you know in the wild more in in
indonesia and the philippines you know
big giant reticulated pythons will take
people a little bit more common again i
don't think like multiple per year but
it does happen i mean just maybe two two
years ago i remember seeing a story of a
woman went out because like her pig was
squealing right and she went out to go
figure out what was happening with the
pig obviously there was a snake there
and the next morning they found her
slippers
and uh and a giant snake with a huge
lump in it and they actually caught the
snake and she was inside oh so yeah she
was deceased so yeah yeah damn but
that's it's a rare thing like i said in
the in in america it's very very rare
you know and again usually
it's
you know listen you know that's why you
shouldn't handle a big snake without
someone else there i have never we've
always had the policy got to have two
people just in case and i've never been
in danger my entire life never once has
a snake almost killed me if a snake
starts swallowing your friend
what do you do what is the other what
are you supposed to do so we we have a
policy as much as i hate to say it is
that if there's ever a situation where
someone's in danger you kill the snake
you know immediately like i mean there's
no second chance you know you can't you
can't take the risk of trying to get
that snake off if it's danger mode right
because if you have a 18 we have snakes
almost 200 pounds you know if that thing
is is for some reason and we've never
had it happen but for some reason that
is is constricting you you don't have
much time i mean that's gonna it's gonna
black you out you know you follow ufc i
mean you'll push someone to sleep pretty
quick right you can imagine a snake this
big it's going to put someone to sleep
real quick you know once you're asleep
will they then do they then let go can
they tell when you're asleep uh they'll
they'll squeeze you till you're done
right you know so they're not going to
you're not just going to please yeah so
you can't play dead you know you can't
be like oh just play dead and they'll
let go i mean it'll it'll hang on to you
for 20 30 minutes you know and and then
then release so what should you do if a
snake started wrapping around you
hit it with your car keys or something
yeah not
99.9999 percent of times when a snake is
wrapping around you it's holding on to
you like it wants like you're a tree
it's just trying not to fall it's just
trying not to fall it is
i've like said i've never experienced a
snake trying to kill me or anyone around
me ever so i don't know what would
trigger a snake um
maybe it's hungry maybe you haven't
taken care of it and haven't fed it
properly i'm not sure i don't know what
would trigger a snake to try to
constrict you i've never seen it so i i
i don't think it's i think people think
it happens right and even you know when
people see me have a giant anaconda
around my neck like isn't it gonna kill
you you know you're like no it's just
hanging on to me man it's like literally
i'm like a tree you know and it's it's
gonna wrap around you so it doesn't fall
right right yeah it's not trying to kill
you um do you uh
is there another question that came in
spence
anything else we want to get to
god
so my question is how do you feel about
like
all the hate that you get people say you
don't take care of your animals correct
whatever
i know watched you for a few years
i'm very interesting it's crazy
taking care of a bunch of reptiles like
that but i just want to feel your
opinion like when all i hate all that
[ __ ] sorry it's windy out here y'all
gang gang when the inside everywhere man
well you know why why do animal people
get so much you don't take care of your
animals why is that such a common thing
in the animal world i think it's it's
always i think it's not just in the
animal world i think that hatred comes
from success right you know just like
you you have a big following i guarantee
you there are people out there that
think you're bad for whatever reason
right people are mean yeah and so like i
can tell you this much no one that's
ever visited my place has ever said i
haven't taken care of an animal you know
what i mean it's always just the people
that like are jealous or like oh my god
this guy's got a big following he's and
and it doesn't even bother me to be
honest with you because i know right i
don't have to prove to anybody what the
deal is i know that i mean you can't go
to a place that's better kept than ours
i mean the animals are impeccably kept
and um and we have a crew that's really
great so so yeah that that stuff i think
that just comes with being successful
you know it comes with people following
you you know when you have five people
that follow you online
no one cares but when you have millions
of people that follow you you know their
voice you know that that minor that
vocal minority and they you know
you know i'm sure you get the same thing
the most crazy things get made up about
me uh that that's wild i'll read
something i'll be like what no we're
like like you know it's like building a
noah's ark yeah yeah who knows you know
i mean i hear all kinds of stuff you
know it's like and and
he's building the noah's ark and you're
like that's [ __ ] insane yeah oh yeah
that's all kind of [ __ ] but i think that
you know as you know in your position
that
you know we we signed up for this number
one right i mean no one told us to
become social media or comedians or
whatever we we decided to do it so we
have to take the good with bad bad the
bad is is loud mouse that like to you
know have their 15 minutes of you know
fame with the keyboard you know yeah and
you have to learn how to just not worry
about it it's a little bit more
difficult you know with animals because
because when someone hears like you're
not taking care of your animals then
people like oh my god he's an animal
abuser whereas if someone's like you
know like theo stole the you know jim
gaffigan's jokes when he was you're like
yeah whatever it didn't matter as much
so people take that more serious but
again i think that's a good point yeah
animal things are hot it's always such a
hot topic i think especially when that
joe dirt uh joe tiger came out yeah
tiger king yeah yeah did you ever run
across that guy i didn't know joe but i
knew almost everyone else in the series
yeah they're almost everyone else in the
series with a friend never mind so it
was it was definitely a very as a matter
of fact the scene if you remember the
scene opens up at a reptile place
if you remember and so he's at a reptile
place guy named tom crutchfield and then
all of a sudden there's a van mark
mccarthy a buddy of mine and there's a
snow leopard in it and he says wow this
took me on a completely different
direction that series was originally
supposed to be a reptile series it
turned into a tiger series because he
just happened to be at my friend tom
crutchfield's place which by the way
they've now filmed that reptile king i
don't know it's called i think it's
going to be called lizard king to be
honest with you because there was a book
called lizard king from brian christie
was a bestseller and um a guy named
ray and mike vanostrum or the lizard
kings um and in their reptile people but
tom crutchfield also was one of the main
guys
that's how that whole thing started was
it was supposed to be shot about raven
nostrum mike vanostrom tom crutchfield
and a couple other guys and it turned
into tiger king but uh but yeah like i'm
friends with mario the the the the guy
that scar faces you know i don't know
yeah the guy he's literally the
scarface was made after him i've known
mario for a long time pretty much all
the guys in the in the series i've been
friends with you know the myrtle beach
doc antler doc antel's wild yeah yeah he
seems interesting
interesting is a word for it yeah that's
exactly what you see that whole thing i
mean listen i don't know how they make
it work man you know like like but they
do like i see what they do with these
animals and i'm like i don't know how
people aren't dying you know but they
they got it oh i don't know his son is
in debt every day and he's out there
eating damn mangoes with a damn um
you know snow cat or whatever yeah no i
mean but it works man i mean they they
they somehow have those animals dialed
in and it's you know like i i don't know
man i mean i i give them a lot of
respect from the standpoint that they
really know their stuff because no one's
ever been hurt there and they are you're
walking around with a liger that's 800
pounds or whatever you know it's like
that's crazy i gotta go over there you
should man just see it i'm supposed to
go to charleston in a couple weeks maybe
i'll try to stop on the way let me know
i'll hook it up man that'd be a great
idea can i help you out man um
is it hard to support like does your
wife and children have other interests
are you so reptiled in that it's ever
like
hard to like uh because i find it hard
in my own life i get so caught up in my
own stuff that it's like man i've
created so many things that are busy
it's hard for me to put them down and
recognize
other people's interests and stuff and
it's not a judgment it's just a
curiosity no i know i think you're 100
right i think that you know
if you're doing things the way
i mean this is a
go back to the balance thing i am so
unbalanced dude you're right you know
yeah i mean like i i work like i work
like way too much i i mean you know it's
hard to have
other interests at all you know what i
mean like like i'd love to go out and
play hockey or play baseball or
something like that on the weekends that
just ain't gonna happen you know i'm too
busy and uh and it's the same thing my
wife is uh you know she's you know 24 7
you know with me so we we try we're
trying you know i mean but it's it's
hard because you've done everything you
can do i feel like yeah well that's
inside be a damn snake right well this
is the thing that's great about my life
and same thing with yours is that
i'm doing all this crazy work but in the
meantime i'm like
you know on a freaking island in the
middle of indonesia you know in a cave
with with snakes you know or or i'm
traveling around or even even you know
like again you know just like the first
time i met you you know i'm going to a
comedy show and then going back and
meeting theo von you know that's what
everything is when i go to a baseball
game i'm meeting the baseball players
you know so i so like
you know so you might work your your
butt off but at the same time you're wit
you're you're winning because you're
living an extraordinary life yeah you
know even though you're working like a
dog you're like doing things that people
can only dream you could do sitting in a
room talking with theovan for two hours
or whatever you know it's like it's it's
a blessing but yeah there's not a lot of
balance man like you know i'm not
sitting around playing bocce ball very
much that's for sure yeah it's tough man
it is interesting and i don't know if it
goes back to something inside of me that
wants to work all the time if it goes
back to a fear of being
like not seen or something i don't know
do you know what made you what drove
what what drives you if you ever thought
back out yeah 100 it's you know the the
typical you know parents never thought
you'd amount to anything you're never
going to be good enough you're never
going to be the you know your brother
and sister going to be more successful
and then you have that chip you know
you're like you're proof i tell people
all the time i've been i've been trying
to you know prove to my my dad that died
10 years ago how good i am you know yeah
and that's what it is right i mean it's
you know i i listen i've got a lot of
pathologies right you know and i know
them all i've been through therapy
plenty you know so so i get it you know
i'm driven because of uh things that
happened to me when i was young but but
at the same thing you know like i've
said it's like i'd rather be driven to
do something great yeah than be driven
to do something wrong you know what i
mean and i could have hey that fork was
in the road when i was 16 17 years old
oh that tongue split at the end yeah i
could have went the other way and i
could have been doing bad things my
whole life you know i mean i tell people
all the time i'm i'm i'm an addict up to
you know more than an addict you can
imagine i just choose my addictions to
be positive addictions and not drugs and
alcohol and and bad stuff right um
interesting
um i got one last question do you uh
when you travel around the world and you
go to these different cultures and stuff
is there a culture that you feel like
that is most closest to nature
that you get like a sense like man these
people are right are so much closer on
the cusp of
of nature than maybe uh
us culture or
of our culture well for me it's always
been the continent of africa you know
what i mean like you know africans uh
are more in tune with animals for sure
wow now you know see australia it
embraces animals but australia you've
been i'm sure yeah yeah i mean they're
very it's like america with an accent
you know really but they but you also
when you go to the store there's a gummy
snakes and there's you know there's
koala bears everywhere and you know i
mean they're very they embrace nature
yeah and there's animal little
sanctuaries and zoos all over you pull
off any yeah you pull off at a damn
truck stop and there's somebody in there
[ __ ] tickling a uh yeah a little
koala or a little uh gnocchi or whatever
that little animal is waka a wok yeah
her little what is it called that
smiling animal oh that's a coca yeah
so uh but but i think the africans are
you know although australians embrace
wildlife they still live in homes and
stuff like that africa especially if you
get into the bush i mean those people i
mean it's a way of life i mean they're
certainly they you know they've got
lions and they've got you know leopards
and they've got rhinos and and elephants
living amongst them and right and it's a
it's a i love being in the bush in
africa you know that's like the probably
purest places i've ever been in my
entire life um
and and the people there are you know i
went to a place called uh uh dectari
school for bush school for kids and they
would take uh they would take these kids
uh from the bush and bring them into
this little camp for two weeks and the
first thing they would teach them is how
to flush a toilet because they had never
seen running water before right and and
i was lucky enough to come in and spend
some time teaching these kids about
wildlife right and and to them wildlife
it can be scary because you wake up in
the morning and you know your uncle
johnny got killed by a lion you know or
whatever so so everything he was the
breakfast chef right yeah exactly and so
uh
but but then you teach them that these
animals can be respected and it's
amazing i mean and i've never been to a
a rural village in africa that they
aren't all smiles and aren't all like
loving life even though they have
virtually nothing and so uh so yeah i
think africa is the place i mean it's a
place i always get called back to right
like when i i want to go and and and
just feel nature that's where you go and
and have you been to africa yeah yes you
have has a great experience yeah i've
had i would say similar you look in some
people's eyes there and it looks like
they go so far back yeah it does it
feels like you're home when you're in
africa and that's what i always say it's
like as a matter of fact there's a great
saying that says once you've your boot
has stepped its foot in africa you can
never get the dust off mm-hmm and and i
think that that's a a real true story
you know it's like it's always calling
for you to come back and i can't wait
till we can do some more traveling get
back to places that i love like that
it's awesome where do your kids like to
go uh well noah is a big traveler uh and
uh uh my my daughter is is uh she's more
like she go to a resort you know
something like she's that type of a
traveler whereas noah is more of an
adventurous traveler i think you know he
over the you know he's been a lot of
places but i think over the rest of his
life he'll be he'll he'll see the places
i've seen you know and and we've been to
some pretty crazy things i mean i've uh
uh again you know some of my travels
have been
ridiculous you know i mean probably the
craziest you know travel thing that i
ever did once was i was in indonesia and
uh there's this this famous uh guy named
brady barr i don't know if you've ever
heard him nat geo guy you know like
presenter you know and there's this
really famous scene where he's in this
cave uh in indonesia in a place called
estano lar and uh he he gets bit by a
big reticulated python right in the
gooch right in the gooch gets some he's
in bat guana right and and he uh he gets
bit and he screams like crazy you pull
them up yeah there's brandy bar and like
i said the the most famous thing brady
ever done was get bit by a reticulated
python in this thing so we had uh i was
in indonesia
i was in indonesia and uh i get this uh
literally i have a piece of loose leaf
lucy paper dude with a map drawn a drawn
map how to get to the cave right now
this cave is on an island called the
bombajou and uh so i and all i have is a
loose leaf paper lucifer's paper
literally says fly from bali to la
bambajo
drive 43 kilometers up to astana ular
and hike an hour down a trail to the
cave that's all i got right so i
literally pack my backpack one change of
clothes i've got some camera gear it's
me and a friend of mine and we get on a
prop plane fly two hours off of bali to
the bombajou get their uh taxi driver
that we had arranged in the beginning
like not taxi but a driver like he's
supposed to take us there we get there
and he's like oh no no i'm not going to
a standalone that's way too dangerous to
get up into that and i'm like what we
literally just flew here right so i
fortunately had a friend that was really
connected in indonesia i call him up he
gets on the phone with him i don't know
what he tells him if he threatens them
bribes them i have no idea so finally
it's like all right let's go we're doing
this you know so we drive 43 kilometers
takes us literally like four hours
because the roads are so bad to get up
there get up there we get into this this
little village called the standular and
uh we have to get uh passage you know
for from the elder you know the chief
like if we can go to the cave because
this is a holy cave and um and and so so
literally like you know you get up there
and you know they probably don't see too
many white people brady barr was the
last white person they probably saw
right and so we uh uh you know all the
village folk are out there laughing
they're smiling taking you know selfies
and all this other stuff and uh and then
they now we got down with the elders
right we go into this dark room about
this size and it's me my friend and and
uh friend cool my friend's cool he's
from california he's cool he's hanging
out and then i've got my translator that
was the guy that drove us here right
he's he's going to translate for us he's
sitting next to me and we go in this
dark room
three elders sitting here rest of the
village behind him now they're all stoic
not even a smile on their face right and
15 minutes out here
you know they're talking back no idea
it's like a survivor at the end of
survivor i'm like what's and you got to
remember there are still parts of
indonesia that headhunt right you know
so at the end of this 15 minutes it's
the end of this 15 minutes i'm not even
[ __ ] you man i was texting my wife
hoping that maybe it would ping off
something saying i don't know if i'm
going to make it out of here alive right
and so at the end of this 15 minutes of
go back and forth the the the lead elder
reaches back and some lady hands machete
at that point i thought i was dead i'm
like okay i'm done i'm i'm done it's
over so that he gets the machete he puts
it on his side everyone stands up walks
out my translator's not saying [ __ ] to
me you know like and i'm like what is
going on you know so finally he says
okay i talked to the chief he said he
will take you to the cave for like what
equated to like 40 bucks right i'm like
oh my i got 40 i saved my life i got an
escrow i'm in you know by the way we
would have never found this cave you is
this tre it was a trail that like an
hour into the bush we would have been
lost in 15 minutes you know but the the
guy took us into the the cave did this
really badass ritual he had like he had
an egg that was in a handkerchief he
like split the machete was to get uh
like off a sacred tree to knock a branch
off and then he puts the branch down
puts the egg on top and then sings this
ritual for safe passage into the cave
and so we go in there and crazy as hardy
as you could ever be at yeah right and
uh and so we're going there back one up
to my my waist no way i mean just
raining bat poop right you know and we
caught some some snakes in there uh and
it was a great adventure man it was a
great adventure you know so i think noah
will have those adventures in the future
as well you know it's probably one of
the coolest things i've ever done i did
fall into the background at one point
killed my camera by the way i had my
camera slip felt into the the background
i was covered in bat crap only had one
change of clothes and that was uh didn't
have to hike an hour back up to this the
thing to drive four hours back home so
yeah damn well if he stays doing comedy
he won't have he'll i mean he'll perform
at the st louis funny bone that's a real
[ __ ] hole yeah so he might not have diff
it might be the same type of [ __ ] hole
with the bat stuff but yeah it'll be
just different type of [ __ ] yeah still
got to wash yourself off at the end yeah
yeah yeah yeah brian barzig man thank
you so much dude for coming and just
spending time with me man i really think
it's fascinating um i wish i'd if i'd
had a snake i'd pet one man i got one
you want one did you guys really bring
it i bring one yeah you want to get it
i was just saying that
i think you should i think you should if
you'd be here with me man i'm here i'm
here man i'm right here all right let's
get one man let's see what's what's
going on and
and where's this snake from brother
oh jesus christ
he shouldn't have done it
so theo i'm gonna start small okay whoa
whoa dog what you doing man come on man
this is small i'm gonna start small i've
got one other snake you gotta check out
but check this out this is called a pie
ball ball pipeline look it's got a
smiley face on it okay and it's got an
upside down smiley face okay come on man
now is these glasses is this gonna scare
him nope not at all this is drama oh
come on man that dude's moving around
bubby
just hold your hands out like this
you're gonna be good he's gonna know i'm
scared because i know i'm scared right
now he's not going to care he doesn't
matter well what about me
you can be scared but you're not going
to be afraid because you're going to
feel it you're going to be like holy cow
that's way cooler than i expected he
can't bite through this can he he can't
bite you ever all right i promise you
okay so what's going to happen then
is can i just put him on the ground can
i put him on the table or should i put
him in the air
what if i have these braces is that
going to scare him
i don't want him scared dude
let me just touch him first
yeah it doesn't feel like it's not slimy
okay cool so
you ready you'll be fine and yeah just
do this real quick and then i got one
other thing i'll show you see that's not
bad right the thought of holding a snake
is way worse than actually holding steak
he's just chilling okay okay good all
right let me show you one more jesus dog
damn bro i think i just had a uh
egg birth in my heart
i feel like i just had a pair of what
y'all
damn boy now this one's gonna go around
your neck
damn bro come on bro this one's gotta go
around your neck all right
this was what super sweet it's the only
way you can hold on dude i can't even
hear you right now
you have to give me at least ten seconds
man to chime in man all right
damn bro all right you're gonna be fine
okay now what is that snake doing
where's that snake from man this snake
is a burmese python it's albino burmese
python and it's not gonna do anything
it's super tame super i mean this is i
mean it seems like it wants to do
something it's around like five-year-old
kids all day long god dude
you ready
yeah now what are you going to do you're
going to put it on me and then what do i
do to sit here sit here and i'll take
them off when you tell me okay all right
super simple well it just hold on dog
it just was breathing it's just
breathing why can't you [ __ ] just
breathe real quietly more quietly dude
it's good it's breathing like a damn
like it's damn we got a v6 in its neck
it's going to be fine
i got you all right okay let's wait till
it's looking away all right i'm going to
take it like this so it's looking away
you tell me when you're ready okay and
it's not going to go up my sleeves or
anything is it should i pin my sleeves
closed nope you're good
you're good i got you all right just
like this yep
like this
and if you put this hand out like that
you can control its head and you're set
see
you did it you proud yeah you won can
you take him i got you thank you brother
you got it jesus christ bro
yeah that was awesome right fears dude
that's what i feel scared good man you
did good you should be proud of yourself
man
that's good stuff isn't it
yeah can i try one more time with you
yes of course okay i just want to feel
out here i want to feel the fear again i
told you
i told you this is how it happens all
right
am i good you're good
he's just kind of cruising around do i
hold him or anything you're good all
right
and how do i seem okay you're good i
mean you seem a little stiff that's fine
he seems fine he's happy
you can move you can breathe you can do
all that normal stuff that people do all
right
ladies and gentlemen we're
grateful we are grateful you're here
tonight
thank you
this episode brought to you by liquid
death
or just regular death
okay what is he looking at he's still
looking at the plant okay good
yeah man he seems wow i think it's just
that
he doesn't seem like a bad guy
no he's a good guy trust me i only
brought good ones okay thank you
okay i think i'm okay for today that's
good though
goodbye buddy there you go wow
you did good brother i'm proud of you
you're powerful
it's like you won it's like you won and
you're winning away i feel a little bit
more
yeah like i want to like just like i did
something you know like i leaned into
the discomfort oh geez no worries
it means it's his lunch time i'm sure
yeah that's it
just in time just in time i took him
back so close yeah he's so close
wow man that's amazing dude yeah it's
cool right i mean when you do it it's
kind of it's mesmerizing right oh yeah
that's what i told you is that people
that just like you you know afraid then
you do it you're like let me do that
again man let me do that again and then
next thing you know you're like really
into it i'm telling you you know if you
were close to me you'd be at my place
every day you'd be like holy crap this
thing is awesome you know when we come
up man oh you a vlog i'll come in there
when we come up and we'll do something
fun man you have to show me around a
little bit i'll try to be more a little
a little bit more brave you're you were
brave man you did great dude i feel good
it definitely makes me feel something it
makes me feel like i did something i
didn't want to do a little bit you know
yeah i feel a little bit more
like uh maybe i don't know if it's maybe
a little bit more confidence i think
you're i think you could see it actually
i could see it in your face you went
from like terrified in the beginning to
almost like wow this is all right i got
this man i got this that's pretty
awesome you should be proud of yourself
i'm proud of you thank you i appreciate
it thank you for being here too man
thanks for boosting my pride level today
uh guys you if you don't know o'brien
you can check him out he has a huge
youtube channel and you can experience
everything that's all about all reptiles
not just snakes right yep right yeah all
reptiles and um he has two children
and he seems like a good guy and we're
happy he was here today thank you so
much bub thanks man it's been awesome
thank you brother yeah it's cool
[Music]
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load
[Music]